[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con la
vicepresidenta de eeuu kamala harris
visitó guatemala y méxico en reuniones
con los presidentes de ambos países fue
enfática en la necesidad de combatir la
corrupción para disminuir la migración
ilegal desde el triángulo norte hasta
eeuu habló de las grandes dificultades
de quienes abandonan sus países de
origen y pidió a los centroamericanos no
ir a la frontera vamos a conversar sobre
este tema con iván velázquez ex jefe de
la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en guatemala cicig iván
bienvenido a france 24 y qué importancia
tiene la visita de la vicepresidenta de
eeuu o kamala harris a guatemala y
méxico
buenos días muchas gracias yo
frente a la situación tan complicada por
la que atraviesa actualmente en
guatemala
esta primera visita de la vicepresidenta
a cualquier país
y demuestra cuál es la importancia que
tiene para eeuu para los guatemaltecos
naturalmente frente a una situación de
extensión muy fuerte de la corrupción y
a una captura de todas las instituciones
del estado incluida la corte de
constitucionalidad creo que podría
generar una esperanza a la población en
ese proceso de construcción de
democracia tan indispensable de
guatemala
eeuu se muestra preocupado no sólo por
el problema migratorio sino por la
corrupción rampante en la región que
sería una de las causas del fenómeno
migratorio cómo combatirla eficazmente
es suficiente la presión que busca
ejercer washington sobre estos gobiernos
indudablemente tiene que producirse una
gran transformación en el país y eso
pasa porque el presidente y amante
escoja socios confiables también dentro
dentro del país abandone alianzas que
tiene compartidos que son corruptos o
que son como decía un embajador de
estados unidos en el 2009 partidos que
son partidos del narcotráfico partidos
políticos que hacen parte de la
coalición de gobierno el presidente
llama 'the y tendría que comprometerse
también con la democracia no es posible
y lograr controlar la migración
si existe un estado de violencia de
inseguridad de las personas y además es
el estado de corrupción que nos lleva a
una desprotección absoluta a unas
condiciones muy deplorables de vida de
existencia en sus regiones bueno y ya
para finalizar pues le quisiera
preguntar a usted qué opina muy
rápidamente sobre la eliminación de la
comisión anticorrupción y de la captura
de los poderes por parte del gobierno
del salvador
me parece que es muy lamentable el
presidente muy que le había dado
muestras de una apertura en su en su
campaña al inicio de su gobierno la
promesa de la creación de la comisión
internacional contra la impunidad en el
salvador
pronto su espíritu autoritario me parece
que el salvador va rápidamente hacia una
dictadura
la manera como como lo viene
desarrollando
lamentable que hubiera
a balcón con la si si es yo creo que
aquí
eeuu está en una difícil situación deja
también la posición que ha asumido el el
propio presidente bucl respecto de eeuu
muchísimas gracias a usted por estar con
nosotros en nuestros televidentes sigan
en france 24
[Música]